[Music]
Taylor Swift surprised fans Thursday
with a brand new song only the young is
her new political anthem she dropped
with the release of her Netflix
documentary and joining us now with a
breakdown of all the truth bombs Taylor
dropped and missed Americana is easy on
lines Katy crass and one of Taylor's
biggest fan that is a true statement I
want to get right into it we have pulled
some of the best clips from the
documentary but I just want to say this
documentary if you love Taylor if you
don't like Taylor you should watch this
it really demonstrates what she's gone
to over the past decade right to really
find herself and her voice and I think
that this quote from the documentary
kind of sums the whole thing up so take
a look one of love glitter and also
stand up for the double standards that
exist in our society I want to wear pink
and tell you how I feel about politics
and I don't think that those things have
to cancel each other out I want to still
have a sharp pen
thin skin and an open heart Wow I love
it you're lying it's a documentary
that's so fascinating cuz you really get
a behind-the-scenes look not just had a
creative process of creating music with
her thought process of where she stands
now in the world kind of her life and
what she's gone through I think one of
the biggest things in there if she does
address Kanye West and what happened in
2009 at the VMAs but she's not throwing
daggers she's not accusing she's keeping
it classy and she's explaining how that
moment made her feel and I want you guys
to check this out for someone who's
built their whole belief system on
getting people to clap for you the whole
crowd booing is a pretty formative
experience that was like sort of a
catalyst for a lot of psychological
paths that I went down
[Music]
not all of them were beneficial she gets
really deep here yeah and that is one of
the biggest themes that we that we see
throughout is how much she got like she
loved the approval right and she loved
his fans and she really measured her
success on how people thought of her and
she does talk about the success of 1989
and winning that Grammy for album of the
year for the second time and how when
you hit the top and you think you have
it all maybe you don't really and it
feels so lonely it feels so lonely yeah
take a look at this clip and I remember
thinking afterward oh my god that was
all you wanted oh god that was all you
wanted that was all you focused on you
get to the mountaintop and you look
around and you're like oh god what now I
want to thank the fans for the last 10
years
I didn't have a partner that I climbed
it with that I could like high-five plot
twist look now she does have a partner
to share all of this with she manifests
anymore well I think with that she kind
of thought to herself I do need a
prioritize life differently right like I
do need a focus I think life is a pie
right and you can't just make it all
career you have to have those moments
for your personal life and I think she
said to herself I don't want to go
through this alone how much of Joe all
when do we see in this documentary so
there's not a time but there is a moment
when she comes off stage and he's back
there and she kind of runs into his arms
there's also a moment where you see and
I think we can actually pull this up for
you guys what fans think an engagement
ring - there it is on that thing it's on
the cat ring again it does look like the
cat ring and I do remember cat yeah but
I see why fans are talking so much about
that moment anything on that finger is
she does talk about Joe a little bit
though and if you'll remember after her
and Kanye kind of went at it again after
the VMAs in just a few years ago when he
released famous there with some beef and
she talked about how Joe kind of came
into her life at that moment and what
that was like for her so take a look I
have to deconstruct an entire belief
system for my own personal sanity I also
was falling in love with someone who had
a really wonderfully normal balanced
grounded life
and we decided together that we wanted
our relationship to be private even
though it was really horrible I was
happy but I wasn't happy in the way that
I'd been trained to be happy it was
happiness without anyone elses input it
was just as we were happy and I feel
like that really is probably the most
we're gonna get out of her yeah this
relationship because like she said they
want to keep it private and I respect
that and again she's here saying that
this is a different kind of happiness
for her right it's another point to that
theme where she's got all of her
happiness and all of her assurances from
how people viewed her and here she's
saying this is different like I don't
need people to like my relationship I
this is a completely new feeling for her
and even though that's as much as we got
on Joe and her boyfriend she did reveal
that she's not quite right that was also
pretty candid for me yeah and there is
one conversation in there where she
actually is talking to her best friend
abigail they've been friends forever
good and they're talking about their
other friend Claire who did just have a
baby and Taylor talks about the cycle of
you feed them and you love them and then
you sleep and then you wake up and then
you change them and you feed them and
you do it again and she kind of compared
it to having a tamagotchi which is
really fine spent too much time on any
one topic when I was watching
documentary walk us through a couple of
the other kind of truths that we learned
yeah so one of my favorite things about
this is the glimpse that we get into her
relationship with her mom Andrea who we
know has had or is going through quite
the difficult cancer battle and just to
see how it's really affected the family
and how it's changed Taylor's
perspective take a look at this clip you
guys it woke me up from this is life
where I used to sweat all these things
but like do you really care if the
internet doesn't like you today if your
mom's sick from her chemo obviously very
emotional yeah and a lot of tears in
this you know when you see how much
Andrea is with Taylor through everything
it was actually a moment where Taylor's
gone through so much negativity and
backlash and her mom breaks down
actually saying this to her so take a
look at this one
it's okay now a lot of yeah a lot of
really sweet mother-daughter moments
here we also see Taylor getting really
emotional she's really vulnerable in
this you guys and take a look at this
moment where she breaks down over the
Taylor Swift is over party hashtag that
happened a few years back and remember
we do remember that um take a look I've
been doing this for 15 years as I'm
tired of it I'm just tired of the
just
just feels like it's more than music now
at this point oh man that's gotta be
hard for an artist to write it's like
you spend your whole life writing these
songs maybe wanting to connect and then
you feel like it's not about the music
anymore it's all about the tabloids in
the rumors and the stories and the few
and you're a human you are a human at
the end of the day and that's why she
said she kind of retreated for a little
bit no and she created all this work but
also she creeped she worked on herself
though too and that's when she really
got political and found her of ways
right you know what
yeah that but also I mean through I mean
we do see that in this documentary
there's a lot of that we played some of
the song earlier there is a portion
though she does talk about her eating
disorder which I think may be the most
vulnerable that Taylor has ever gotten
the most she's really shared about kind
of struggles she went through
take a look yeah you don't ever say to
yourself look I've got an eating
disorder but you know you're like making
a list of everything you put in your
mouth that day and you know that's
probably not right I'm a lot happier
with Who I am and I'm happier with like
I don't I don't care as much if like
somebody points out that I have gained
weight it's just something that makes my
life better the fact that I'm
I'm a size six instead of a size double
zero I mean a lot of things that people
may not have known about her in this
document and I think after they watch
that they're just gonna look at her in a
different way and like you see how many
people on her team were trying to
influence her and telling her what to
speak out about what not to say I came
into play with a whole political thing
her own dad yeah did not want her to
post that first Instagram statement
where she really talked about politics
for the first time in fact those
candidates in Tennessee who are
Democrats
it was pretty heated take a look at this
though they told her they're like you're
gonna have backlash the president is
gonna come after you verse one she
literally did not care I don't care what
they write that I'm sad that I didn't
two years ago the president could come
after you yes bad I don't care she you
know what ain't good for her good for
her that she's using her platform to
speak out for what she wants and set
that precedent and again I mean we
really see how she came to find her
voice and how it was really hard I think
for women in country music to speak out
on what they believe and to have a voice
and not just to be what she calls like a
good little girl girl like like you
mentioned whether you're a Taylor Swift
fan or not you will see her a difference
see her in a different light and I
really recommend it actually miss
Americana is streaming now on that thank
you thanks guys
[Music]